welcome back everyone it's Charlie these
are going to be all my Joker movie Easter
eggs and Batman references there were 10
of Batman comic book Easter eggs
previous Batman films reference previous
versions of the Joker and other non
comic book films we're doing a giveaway
for movie tickets all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Joker moment please do use
spoiler tags for at least the next week
or so because there's so people that
haven't seen the movie yet
and obviously spoiler warning for
everything that happens in the movie
because we'll be talking about very
specific plot points first big Easter
Egg starts with the Warner Brothers logo
at the beginning of the movie is the
same logo from Superman to with
Christopher Reeve that's because that
was the standard Warner Brothers logo
for all Warner Brothers movies between
1972 and 1984 is the very first
indicator of when the movie is supposed
to take place even though they never
actually tell you what the exact year is
during the movie but what they do have
is a couple movie release Easter eggs at
the end of the movie like Zorro the
blade wolfin Excalibur the Arthur movie
those were all 1981 movie releases so we
can say it's probably taking place
during 1981 the Sanitation strike that's
going on in Gotham is a reference to the
Sanitation strikes in real life New York
City history through the 70s and 80s and
the New York City fiscal crisis of the
70s Joker's real name Arthur Fleck is
not a comic-book reference Todd Phillips
said that he picked it because it
sounded like speck or flake making the
Joker as a character seem more
insignificant as a person the social
worker he speaks to during the movie is
named Deborah Kane in honor of Batman
co-creator Bob Kane the bank where
Sophie his imaginary girlfriend works is
on William Street that's a reference to
Bill Finger other Batman co-creator
later we see a subway stop at Robinson
Park another reference to former Batman
artist Jerry Robinson Joker lives in
apartment 8 jj4 Joker in 8 because he's
the 8th big movie version of the Joker
Joaquin Phoenix's iconic Joker lap is
actually an affliction that he develops
as a result of childhood abuse
and head trauma comic book Joker gets
his iconic laugh after he falls into the
vat of chemicals and Batman The
Joke undergoing his physical and
psychological transformation there's a
more literal Joke Easter Egg
when he goes to the Charlie Chaplin
modern times screening the camera
lingers on the protesters holding up
signs one of the signs says Joke
and speaking of that Batman story Arthur
in the movie is also an aspiring
comedian just like Joker was during
Joke there are also two other
Joker stories that reference his early
comedic ambitions before he became the
Joker
there was a tie-in comic book that they
made for the Batman 1989 film with
Michael Keaton in Jack Nicholson called
the further adventures of Joker
anthology published in 1990 which
features Jack Nicholson's Jack Napier
character spending his early life
scrawling jokes in notebooks just like
Arthur does during the movie there was
also an episode of batman the animated
series called laughing up where they did
a version of Joke origins story
showing Joker trying and failing to
become a stand-up comedian before he
became the Joker
I'll ruin your I think I see what you
mean Alfred without the Hat different
hair the Joker the sand of comedy club
that he goes to for practice is called
pogos which is named after Pogo the
clown the alias used by John Wayne Gacy
Arthur's relationship with his deranged
mother is a reference to Norman Bates
relationship with his mother in the
movie psycho and even though I don't
totally buy that she was telling the
truth about Arthur being Thomas Waynes
son on the back of her picture Thomas
Waynes message to her reads love your
smile TW a reference to the Joker's
smile then a very big Heath Ledger
Batman Dark Knight Joker reference at
the end of the film when he's painting
the smile on his face
in blood you want to know how I got
these scars the actor Bret Cohen in real
life who plays Thomas Wayne says that
it's his opinion that Thomas Wayne drove
penny crazy 30 years ago and is
responsible for her being put in Arkham
Asylum but that's not the opinion of
Todd Phillips the writer and director of
the movie as for whether or not Joker is
actually Thomas Wayne's son in the film
Todd Phillips only said that he wrote it
that way to make Joker believe that he
was Thomas Wayne's son as a way to give
him a compelling reason for hating
Batman so much later when Batman would
eventually become Batman he didn't say
that penny was telling the truth
Phillips only said that he wanted Joker
to believe that it was the truth not
that it was the actual truth but there
is an actual canonical comic book
version of Joker that is Thomas Wayne's
son and that is the Batman who laughs
because the Batman who laughs is a
version of Bruce Wayne from the dark
multiverse who turned into a version of
the Joker Joker goes on a date with the
fake version of Sophie that he
hallucinates but the date takes place on
Jerome Avenue the character Jerome
Valeska on the Gotham TV show turned
into the Joker the crazy dance that the
Joker does inside the bathroom is a
reference to a Grant Morrison Batman
story Batman number 663 the clown
@midnight in it the dance is meant to be
a metaphor for him undergoing a
transformation emerging from a cocoon
like a chrysalis as his arms unfurl like
he's evolving from a caterpillar into
the butterfly Jo
Joker confessing to his crimes on the
Murray Franklin TV show only bear is
both a reference to the Zodiac movie
with the Zodiac calling in live
to confess and then Joker Murray
on live TV is a reference to Batman The
Dark Knight Returns part 2 where the
Joker an entire live studio
audience on TV
Joker you've asked for a chance to share
your side of things I'm told you've
about 600 people how exactly does
your side of that go that's why I'm
gonna everyone in this room more
fun Batman the Animated Series Easter
eggs the font that Murray Franklin's TV
show uses is also the same as the title
font from Batman the Animated Series
earlier in the film when Joker goes to
Wayne Manor and meets Bruce Wayne Bruce
slides down the pole in his tree house
just like 1966 Adam West's Batman
we also wound up meeting the younger
version of Alfred during that encounter
but obviously at the end of the movie
the Wayne's are outside the
theater in Crime Alley the movies are
all Easter eggs for Batman's origin in
the comics and other Batman movie origin
stories Zorro the blade is just an
updated version of the Mark of Zorro
from the original version of his origin
story in the 1940s it's just that that
was the version of Zorro playing at that
time and the newer version of Zorro was
playing in 1981 when this movie is
supposed to take place Excalibur is also
a reference to the Batman V Superman
opening scene and of course Joe Chill
wearing a clown mask Thomas
Wayne and Martha Wayne in front of Bruce
Wayne giving us our classic Batman
origin story reference they even do the
shot of the pearls flying off the fact
that he's wearing the clown mask is also
a wink at the Tim Burton Batman origin
story where it was the Joker himself
Jack Napier who committed the act
instead of comic book Joe Chill have you
ever danced with the devil in the pale
moonlight
you could try to draw references between
Batman V Superman and Ben Affleck's
version of Batman in this young version
of Bruce Wayne the timeline would line
up for those versions a lot of people
wondering how this is tied to the new
Batman trilogy that's coming up with
Matt Reeves and Robert Pattinson
because that's supposed to take place
during the 90s the only way that would
work out is if that movie takes place in
the late 90s because this version of
Bruce Wayne looks like he's barely 10
years old but of course todd phillips
was asked this very specific question if
this version of the Joker franchise
would ever crossover with Matt Reeves
Batman trilogy and his answer was
basically no Robert Pattinson was just
cast as Batman I know this is a totally
different movie but but do you see those
two worlds merging together anytime soon
no most of you also probably noticed the
liberal Easter eggs for Martin
Scorsese's taxi driver in the king of
comedy jokers origin story from Arthur
to joker follows a very similar path to
Travis bickel's story during taxi driver
as well as Robert De Niro's main
character from the king of comedy who
seeks to gain recognition and fame
through terrible acts the Joker in the
movie is looking for people to notice
him people are finally starting to
notice me there were a lot of visual and
story references to both of those movies
- like when Travis Bickle is sort of
playing with the gun dancing around with
his shirt off the Joker is dancing
around accidentally setting the gun off
sorry mom it was just an old war movie
that I was watching there's also the
very notable Charlie Chaplin easter-egg
modern times is playing during the movie
at Wayne Hall Joker goes to try and
confront Thomas Wayne about his
parentage the plot of Charlie Chaplin's
modern times movie is all about the
plight of the working man during the
Great Depression it's all about class
struggle in class struggle is a big
theme of the Joker movie wall the clown
mask riots are happening outside the
theater that's why they focus so much on
the visual differences between the riots
and the streets and how crazy dirty and
awful everything looks - when he steps
inside the theater and it's almost like
he's stepping into a palace as far as
sequels go Joaquin Phoenix hasn't really
said anything about him coming back to
do anymore
I'm sure the movies already broken a
couple of October records it's smashed
Venom's October record which is a new
all-time wreck
for highest-earning October movie
release but as I've said in previous
Joker movie videos that I've done my
most likely assumption is that they'll
just try to do another DC Black Label
film with another villain character or
another Batman comic book character just
a really focus smaller film based on a
single character so you get a Riddler
movie or maybe they would try to do a
war of jokes and riddles movie where
it's basically a Joker versus The
Riddler movie with a little bit of
Batman stuff in it but he's not the main
character it's just about the Joker
going to war with the Riddler
or they do a DC Black Label film about
the penguin or Rachel Ghul any of his
iconic comic book villains so if you
spotted any big Easter eggs during the
movie that I didn't mention in the video
just write them below in the comments
let me know if there are any big
questions that you have about the film
well obviously everyone's still going to
be talking about what's real and what's
fake about that ending I've already done
a video about the ending of the movie
I'll include a link to that at the end
of this and in the description
congratulations JC for your the giveaway
winner from my last big Joker video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details
everybody click here for my Joker ending
scene video and click here for my Joker
review thank you so much for watching
everybody put on a happy face I'll see
you guys tonight